[Music]
why is your mom running for office why
do you think you want to help out you're
seeing people get put down for stupid
reasons you think okay so you're running
to help solve that every time you come
here do you think I hope I work here
like stop here and look at it and kind
of try to take it in the things that
happen here and the impact they have on
people it just makes me like stop I feel
very much like at home but also super
inspired by it for the past few years
nonprofit founder Brittney Wallisch has
been advocating and testifying for bills
as a Wyoming citizen now she's
campaigning for a state Senate seat in
the hopes of writing those bills
[Music]
Brittany says she's running because when
she sits in the gallery she doesn't see
herself or many of her peers represented
and not just because she's a Democrat in
a conservative state there's a lot of
men in the Senate so many so that like
the two women that I can see from where
I'm sitting right now they just really
stand out don't they they look very much
at home yeah and they are they're
brilliant in their own right but it is
an obvious imbalance I mean your
representation should reflect your
population our women have not fared well
in this legislative session if elected
brittany hopes to fight for a wide range
of causes as the founder of an animal
rescue she cares deeply about animal
welfare issues and the nonprofit sector
she pledges to fight for public school
funding and she wants to close Wyoming's
gender wage gap which is among the
largest in the nation we shouldn't be
surprised by the sound of a woman's
voice in the legislature in Wyoming 15%
of the state legislators are women
making it the third worst state in terms
of female representation it's a
statistic that undermines the motto of
the so-called Equality state where 150
years ago
Wyoming's territorial government became
the first in the nation to permanently
grant women the right to vote and hold
office a full 50 years before the
passage of the 19th amendment the state
is honoring the historic milestone and
Wyoming's 14 female lawmakers have been
at the forefront of the celebration it
was 1869 were down the street the
territorial legislature met and that's
where the actual vote happened
and so when Wyoming became a state in
1890 there was debate in Washington DC
about whether or not women could come in
with its guarantee suffrage for women
and I believe when representative in the
house said I would be anarchy if we let
women vote we can't do it hey Wyoming
sent a telegram back saying we would
rather stay out of the Union 100 years
than to come in without our women and so
those words and that's
it was echoed really very very much in
this room that were sitting in today
this room known as the historic
territorial house chamber is where
Wyoming representatives enshrined
women's suffrage in the States
Constitution becoming the first state to
do so we always like to say they didn't
receive the right we had the right the
right was recognized I think is
important to say that our participation
was recognized by the men who were
signing the bill while the motives for
passing the suffrage bill were mixed and
tainted by racism and political antics
the equal rate sentiment prevailed and
Wyoming proudly claims having the first
female justice of the peace the first
female juror the first female bailiff
and the first female governor in the
1980's Wyoming was among the state
legislatures leading the nation in
female representation then the numbers
started to shift after Wyoming
transitioned from multi-member districts
where voters choose multiple people to
represent them to single-member
districts where voters select just one
representative I took my daughter to
watch the Senate debate at the time
there was only one woman serving and she
looked in the chamber and she didn't see
any women serving and so she asked can
girls be in there and I said of course
there's one and she had just announced
she was retiring and so just this notion
that would have you know she's replaced
by a man there might be no women in that
chamber thank goodness she asked me that
question Wyoming women made small gains
in recent years but they say the
structure of the legislature is still
tilted against them the legislature was
set up in order to accommodate these
schedules
honestly of the men who lived here at
that time a hundred and fifty years ago
we had a ranch economy we still have
that same schedule today I think it has
been years since we have had a woman who
has lived outside of Cheyenne with both
a fee and Sue live in Cheyenne here who
has had children school-aged children
are younger Wyoming Heights outside of
Cheyenne must endure long drives in
winter conditions in order to serve
so many end up staying in hotels which
can be expensive and especially
challenging for mothers of young
children it's a citizen legislature and
lawmakers are only paid a one hundred
and fifty dollar a day salary and up to
one hundred and nine dollars per diem
when they're working there's no
childcare at the Capitol and the hours
can be grueling it's a grind it's a
grind and who can do that you honestly
see an awful lot of older retired men
it's the same people who were here that
hundred plus years ago one question I
get that I almost guarantee they never
get is who watches your kids when you're
doing this is your husband a good
babysitter and then when I get those
questions it makes my skin crawl
my husband doesn't babysit our children
he's raising our children and you know
so there are definitely differences in
Wyoming women have outnumbered men in
terms of voter participation but that
has not translated to a significant
increase in female representation to try
and change that these lawmakers
co-chaired an event in February down the
road from the capital called leap into
leadership which was founded by their
former colleague Rosie Berger more than
a decade ago with leap into leadership
when I envisioned what it would look
like it was about bringing you to
Cheyenne to experience your government
first you need to know what it is you're
running for or why you would want to be
involved in your government so you need
to come and be comfortable and you need
to have access the two-day event offers
women like Brittney a chance to learn
from others who have run for office
there's no shortage of advice and
panelists also offer a candid assessment
of life on the campaign trail
[Music]
the person for this or like they need to
be asked to do things now I thought I
was a Wonder Woman I could do it all and
and truly I was wrong if you take
nothing else away from this event today
make it this do not wait to be asked
Britany first attended leap a few years
ago and said the event helped demystify
the process of running for office as she
has returned over the years leap has
helped her build a network and she has
looked to Rosie for advice there they're
gonna talk about you
everybody's gonna talk about you win or
lose and that's why you need other
people also defray some of the
negativity from Facebook and various
other places you are a Republican yeah
Britney is a Democrat right why are you
a Republican helping a Democrat because
I want common sense capable individuals
who love their state to represent our
people and to get the work done and
Britney brings another perspective to
the table she brings a young perspective
to the table I saw the numbers reduced
for both the minority party and for
women in particular and that's not
healthy for an institution after a day
of speakers networking and panels the
event brings attendees and prominent
politicians together for cocktails and
dinner Cynthia Lummis has run and won
thirteen times and she credits the old
multi-member district girls for her
first victory more than 40 years ago she
most recently served as Wyoming's sole
representative in the US House a
position that has been held by women for
more than two decades now she's running
to be Wyoming's first female senator are
enough women running for office
they're never enough women running for
office here and elsewhere
you know John Boehner who was Speaker
when I was in the Congress he used to
say if women don't run women can't win
and I know it sounds self-evident right
but
they want to be asked and I would say
don't wait to be asked just do it just
do it
giant beer powerful women it took you
roughly six years to decide to jump in
haha why so long I was still developing
my business I went back to graduate
school and also like I was kind of
afraid to do it how do you measure the
success of a program like leap it's very
difficult let's say one tenth of the
group that probably will run we have
another probably 20 to 30 people that
say that will help on a campaign and do
some part to make it effective I knew
that we were not going to change those
numbers overnight why is something like
leap so special why do you take the time
to be a co-chair because we believe in
the importance of female representation
all voices need to be at the table I
think an overarching theme is that women
really need a network they really need
to be empowered by other women this
program I think is one of those ways in
which you can connect women who have
been successful or have been through
that process and it really starts to
create that social network I know that
it's going to be an uphill battle and I
know that most of the time it's not
going to be a win but a win is possible
and that is enough to keep me going